so what we're going to do in this video
is look at a series of vectors and we're
going to draw them in standard form
where their initial points or their
tails are going to sit at the origin and
we're going to see if we can figure out
the angles that they form the positive
angles that they form with the positive
x-axis and like always pause this video
and see if you can figure out what these
thetas are going to be on your own and
we're going to figure them out in
degrees
so in this first one i have the vector u
if we were to write it in unit vector
notation sometimes it's called
engineering notation we would say it's 3
times the unit vector in the horizontal
direction the i unit vector plus four
times the unit vector in the vertical
direction or you can view this as the x
component is three and the y component
is four and you see that here if you
start at the origin we're going to move
3 in the horizontal direction and we're
going to move 4 in the vertical
direction now to figure out this theta
there's a couple of ways to think about
it we could just construct a right
triangle for this one in particular we
could say okay the x coordinate is three
so if we were to create a right triangle
here
this side would have a length of three
and then
we have a height of four or the y
coordinate is four
this side has a length of 4 and we know
just from even our basic sohcahtoa
definitions of trig functions that what
trig function involves the opposite of
an angle so the opposite of the angle
and the adjacent of an angle well
tangent does sohcahtoa so we know
we know that the tangent
of theta is going to be equal to the
length of the opposite side
which is 4
over the length of the adjacent side
over 3. and so if we wanted to solve a
four theta we could just say that theta
is equal to the inverse tangent
sometimes people say arc tangent of four
thirds
of four
over
over 3. and let's evaluate this and i'm
going to get my calculator out to do it
so
i want to take
divided by 3
which is that
and i already had press this button
right over here that takes my tangent
and makes it into an inverse tangent so
i'm going to take the inverse tangent of
this
and i get
i get roughly
53.1 degrees
so this is approximately
53.1
degrees which looks about right this
looks like a little bit more even though
i didn't draw it completely super
precisely i had drew this it looks a
little bit more than a 45 degree angle
so that that feels that feels pretty
good
now another thing you might have said
hey well look 4 is the y component 3 is
the x component and so maybe tangent of
theta is always going to be the y
component over the x component and that
in fact is the case and that actually
comes straight out of the unit circle
definition of the trig functions where
you could say that if you have a unit
circle
if you have i could draw it right over
here so let me draw
the coordinates
so if i were to draw a unit circle right
over here
and if i were to have some line here
we're thinking about vectors
that the angle formed with the positive
x-axis the tangent of that angle
tangent of theta
is going to be the y-coordinate where we
intersect the circle over the
x-coordinate and so you can imagine if
you made a unit circle right here if you
made a unit circle right over here
the ratio between the y-coordinate and
the x-coordinate of this point right
over here where we intersect the circle
is going to be the same thing as the
ratio between four and three so this is
going to be this also is going to be one
and one third or or four thirds so
either way you can think of when you
think about vectors the tangent of the
angle that forms with the positive
x-axis
is going to be
is going to be the y-component over the
x-component so it's nice when everything
kind of fits together like that so let's
leverage that to figure out this to
figure out this angle right over there
well we could say
that tangent
of theta is going to be equal to the y
component
with the y component over the x
just in a new color or let's see over
negative 5. so it's going to be negative
negative six-fifths or we could say
theta
so let's be a little bit careful so we
we could say we could say that theta is
equal to
is equal to
the the inverse tangent let me do that
same color
inversed
inverse tangent of i'll just write it
like this negative six fifths i'm gonna
put a little question mark here to see
if we feel good about the answer we get
when we do this so let's do that
so if we do
if we do
6 divided by 5 which is equal to that
and then we want to make this negative
so that's negative six-fifths and we're
gonna take the inverse tangent so i
already press this button so this is
going to be an inverse tangent not
tangent
i get negative roughly negative 50.2
degrees
so this is approximately negative
50.2 degrees well does that look right
well no theta looks like it's over 90
degrees negative 15.2 degrees
negative 50.2 degrees is actually giving
us
is actually giving us this angle right
over here so that's giving us that's
specifying another vector if you think
about a line another line that would
have the same tangent
the same 10 so it's really important to
visualize this and think about this and
the reason why it is is because the arc
tangent or the inverse tangent functions
in calculators they will give you an
angle that is between negative 90
degrees and positive 90 degrees so
something that's in the fourth or first
quadrant well here we have something
that's in the second quadrant so we have
to make sure that we're thinking about
it right so that we can make the
appropriate adjustment so that would
give that would give the case if we were
looking at a line like that or a vector
like that so in order to figure out what
in order to figure out the actual angle
what we want to do is add 180 degrees to
it
so
to get the vector that goes in the other
direction
so you want to add so theta
is going to be equal to or i could say
approximately equal to negative 50.2
degrees plus
180 degrees
so let's do that so
so let me plus
180 is equal to approximately
129.8 degrees
so theta
is approximately equal to 129.8
degrees did i get that right have a very
short memory okay yeah that's right
129.8 degrees and that looks much closer
that looks much better that looks it
clearly is an angle we're going to go
that takes us to 90 degrees and then
we're going above 90 degrees now another
way you could have thought about this is
what you know from from sohcahtoa and
just right triangles we could construct
a right triangle
where let me construct a right triangle
using some colors well we know so i can
maybe just draw it like this so
this is the height of it and what is
that height
well we the height is going to be six
and then the base
the base right over here
what is that length going to be well we
know that we're going from the origin
we're going five back but if we think
about just the absolute value the length
of that line that is going to be five
and so we could figure out just using
right triangles this angle maybe we call
that
x and so we could say the tangent of x
tangent of x is equal to 6 over 5
opposite over adjacent
over 5
or that x
or you could say x is equal to the
inverse
inverse tangent of six-fifths
and what is that going to be
so
if we take six divided by 5 1.2 and then
we're going to take the inverse tangent
of that and we get approximately 50
50.2 degrees
so x
is approximately
50.2 degrees which looks right but
remember we're not trying to figure out
x we're trying to figure out
we are trying to figure out what theta
what theta is and you can see that x and
theta are supplementary so theta plus x
is going to be 180 or theta is going to
be 180 minus that
so 180 minus that so let's just put a
negative sign in front of that and add
180 and that might look familiar
so that gets us to 129 roughly
129.8 degrees is exactly what we got
before